à elancourt les tablettes ont remplacé
les cours d'histoire d'anglais et de
poésie lors de la causerie qu à l'école
de lavilledieu une animation pédagogique
dédié à l'apprentissage du code est
proposé ce qui nous a semblé intéressant
c'est que là les enfants aujourd'hui
vont apprendre selon une application qui
s'appelle swift play ground a programmé
une application mobile sur leurs
tablettes
300 enfants de cm1 et cm2 apprennent à
créer une application mobile en
s'amusant
le but former les élèves dès le plus
jeune âge et les préparer aux métiers de
demain
et bien non la cause loïc s'inscrit dans
le dispositif d'école numérique
d'elancourt une satisfaction tant pour
les élèves que les professeurs je trouve
que pour une première approche sami en
émulation toute la classe ils ont été
très heureux vous pouvez le voir de
découvrir l'application find et je pense
que pour une première approche c'est
vraiment très intéressant mais on ne va
pas s'arrêter là à mon avis le conseil
départemental et l'éducation nationale
réfléchisse à un projet proposé à
l'ensemble des douze villes de
l'agglomération de démarrer en janvier
un programme d'équipement et de
formation dans les écoles élémentaires
avec toujours le même but
l'apprentissage du numérique